Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dan from the United
Kingdom. Dan, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi, David, can you hear me? I can.
Speaker 6: Oh, that's good, it's on a map.
I'm sorry. The same goes, I'm sorry. You know,
I kind of had a couple of questions. I'm sorry.
I ran with own kind of concerns of political
apathy because I'm aware I to be following
this because we've got our own troubles over
here that the Virginian governor writes. I
noted that there was about three point three
million votes in the in that race, and that's
kind of a high compared to a previous election.
But right when you think about that and sort
of comparison to the presidential election,
that was kind of a million votes lower. And
then when you think about sort of primary
votes more broadly, that often sort of miles
lower than the actual general election. But
that's why you can kind of get the most ideological
diversity among the parties and you could
probably get the most change. How do you think
we could? So oh, how we I mean countries more
general where you've got sort of 40 percent
of the public not voting even in the main
elections, you hold local government here.
Sometimes elections can barely get 20 percent
of the vote and they control a lot of power.
So I don't know what your thoughts are on
that one.
Speaker 1: So listen, there's a couple different
answers to this. One answer is that the idealistic
answer would be, Well, listen, the way we
get people interested here, Dan, is we have
to make sure everybody understands the direct
link between they're going out to vote even
in midterms and local municipal elections
and the things that happen in their community.
As soon as you explain this to people, you're
going to see voter turnout increased dramatically.
It's kind of B.S. in the sense that it's been
tried so many ways, and it just never really
seems to work like there's just low turnout
in the U.S. and then there's even lower turnout
for midterms. It's just there's just lower
turnout. And the problem with that is that
it disproportionately helps whoever can be
the most salacious in their campaign. And
in Virginia, it was Republicans who used fear
and anger to get Republican voters out to
fight critical race theory, which they wrongly
believe is being taught in schools. So my
real answer would be like the idealistic answer
is let's just explain to people how important
it is to participate. It doesn't really work
very well. A lot of people see it almost as
a badge of honor that they don't work. They
they don't go, they don't vote. Rather, some
people see it as a badge of honor not to work,
but we're talking about voting here. They
see it as a badge of honor not to vote. And
if voting is not mandatory, that's considered
completely valid. And that's that's that's
the way it is. So the next step would be,
well, just you make voting mandatory like
it is in many countries. Yeah, I just don't
think you're going to see it in the U.S. I
think it goes against sort of like the idea
of of the funding. Fundamental principles
of the United States wouldn't even
Speaker 6: happen,
Speaker 1: wouldn't be
Speaker 6: outright exempt, wouldn't even
happen. So they wouldn't be happening.
Speaker 1: I think where we end up, unfortunately,
Dan, is we have to accept that 40 percent
of eligible voters won't vote in presidential
elections and 60 percent won't vote in midterms.
And you just have to figure out how do you
win and achieve change given that reality,
it's it's depressing, I know, but I think
that that's where we're at now.
Speaker 6: I don't know if you've got time
for one more. Yeah, it was kind of sort of
linked to this, I guess like when you kind
of you can, I guess in any election, you might
get sort of a dozen or so call broad categories
of policy discussed. But often as you kind
of talked about something like critical race
theory or the opposition to teach for something
which is really taught. Yeah, is I guess if
you if you kind of line up things by sort
of harm they cause, I guess climate change
could be one corruption, maybe another lack
of health care. And so but we sometimes can
get the least kind of bad, the ones that do
the most damage when they get the least focus,
if they were kind of. Is there a way of school
like as maybe as activist or perhaps preventing
the media changing media environment and you
kind of read so. Is there a way to recalibrate
sort of public discourse to focus on things
that cause sort of the most harm, rather than
something like the risk of dying from COVID
is like 100 times or greater than being killed?
Speaker 1: Unfortunately, unless you change
the infrastructure around how corporate media
works, you're not going to change that because
when you have profit driven media that wants
to focus on the most salacious and titillating
stories. Unless you change the fact that there's
a big reward for that, I don't know how you
make the changes to the discourse that you're
talking about. I mean, part of it would be
counter options. So we've seen the growth
of longform podcast discussions and all these
different things, and that's great. But it's
also great because it's profitable to write.
If it if it were completely not viable, then
you wouldn't see that either. So that's more
of a cultural thing. I don't think you change
it by changing media. I think media will change
as the culture changes around what's profitable
and what what gets eyeballs.
Speaker 6: You know, I have to I often kind
of move towards like sometimes I think the
best thing to sort of longform podcasts or
longform discussions about a single topic
rather than sort of clickbait headlines because
they don't really go into any debt. So I kind
of try to diversify what I'm listening to
beyond just a typical headline, no matter
what, the BBC does a decent job where they
may not be brilliant, but at least they're
not like you can get in-depth explainers on
that. They do a better job, but that's not
perfect. Thanks for taking a
Speaker 1: pleasure, Dan from the UK. Great
to hear from you. Let's see if he can redeem
himself. I'm going to go to Eric from Cancun,
who had a disastrous call last time he called
in. Eric, I'm giving you another shot. OK?
Oh. Eric, you got to unmute yourself, my friend.
Oh, boy. Going from bad to worse for Eric
from Cancun. Eric, you are on the air, this
is your last chance, you've got to unmute
yourself, reconfigure your microphone, otherwise
we're not going to be able to talk. All right,
there it is, Eric, from Cancun attempting
to redeem himself, but it didn't work. It
just didn't work. Let's try. Let's try Kevin
from Seattle. Kevin, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Mr Pacman, can you hear me? I can.
Excellent. Thanks for taking my call. I have
a quick question related to infrastructure,
and I don't know what what your opinion is
on this, but I think leaving the bipartisan
infrastructure bill leaving it idle is very
risky. Like, it doesn't help Biden's approval
ratings Democrats approval rating, especially
Terry McAuliffe. It doesn't help the furloughed
workers who are working to fix our infrastructure,
and it sucks up so much oxygen in Congress
from other issues. And the American people,
like the bipartisan infrastructure bill, once
see and feel like those representing them
could get something accomplished once. So
my question is, is there credence credence
to like the moderate position from like a
progressive point of view, like is holding
up the infrastructure bill damaging to the
material interests of the American people?
Speaker 1: Yeah. So I think leaving the bill
idle is bad for everybody. I think either
listen. Vote on the bill. Kill the bill. If
that's what people in Congress want to do.
House and Senate. Or pass some version of
the bill. And it's time to move on. It's been
going on for months. These bills are by and
large, popular with the American people. There's
disagreements about specific elements of it,
but I completely agree with you just the ongoing
negotiation used to get oxygen by people like
Kirsten Cinema, Joe Manchin and others. It's
not. It's a disaster for the American people.
It's got to end, and just letting it sit idle
also is right. So either kill it or pass it,
and then we've got to move on to the next
thing. I agree with you 100 percent.
Speaker 3: All right. I think that's that's
all I I think if anything, I can get my head
around like what or want. Why? Why do you
like it opposite an opposition? Like, why
is this like that? The hill to die on? Like,
if you care about them, the American people,
then I think we shouldn't think the bill should
be voted on based on its merits rather than
just the owners.
Speaker 1: Those are just I don't think they
see it as a hill to die on. They're just like,
Yeah, I'm just I'm not the people who are
sort of like just against it, which is basically
Republicans. Joe Manchin keeps talking about
it because he's using it to get attention,
and he may actually ultimately vote for it.
Republicans aren't really dying on the hill.
They're just like, Yeah, we don't want it,
so we don't support it. And then and then
they move on. So it's actually doing far more
damage to Democrats. Kevin, I got to run.
I appreciate the call. Kevin from Seattle.
I appreciate everybody I was able to speak
to today. That's going to do it for today.
We're going to go to a break. I hope to speak
to you again next time we take live calls.